hey guys i'm here with Mark a mandir
he's the editor-at-large of the week and
I wanted to bring in somebody that is a
political insider I think I'm a
political outsider I read a lot about
this stuff I see what's going on on
Twitter but I'm on the outside right
we're doing this on the Internet I'm on
the outside I want to talk somebody on
the inside because I'm talking about
this stuff all the time and I always
have a sense that maybe as an outsider I
don't know what's exactly going on so
you've got some insider knowledge fair
to say it's fair to say although i think
in recent years people have grown more
skeptical of insiders in Washington yeah
there's so much being talked about Osama
bin Laden and the raid now you wrote the
original story breaking this is the
secret basically of our raid into
Pakistan and what happened and then last
week there's this article by seymour
hersh that's now saying maybe the
government knew more than they let on
and now just in the last couple days
there's all these new leaked documents
and photos about what was going on in
the bin Laden compound so I think I sort
of got that correct right over there so
sorry so let's start first the seymour
hersh article does that contradict
anything that you wrote about or how do
you feel about well look yes I mean it
is the narrative of the seymour hersh
article is that the u.s. government lied
to everyone as part of a grand
conspiracy involving Saudi Arabia and
Pakistan and Afghanistan in order to
ensure that the death of Osama bin Laden
benefited everyone equally in the region
there are things about his story that
are true and there are some big things
about her story that just aren't true
there was certainly at the time elements
particularly very sensitive intelligence
operations that the CIA didn't
emphasized and want to talk about for
example it was true that they had
confirmation that there was something
unusual Nibhana bad because of a walk-in
source this has been reported before and
Hearst reports it they didn't want to
talk about that because the source is
very sensitive they don't want to send
but they don't want to put the sources
life in danger which generally happens
there was no conspiracy but I will say
this about
about seymour hersh he deserves the
benefit of the doubt because for 35
years seymour hersh has been telling you
that the government is lying to you
about these very basic things of law and
order of Warren peece and he's been
right he's been right almost every
single day on something's wrong but he's
gotten a lot of stuff really really
really right right so someone with that
track record deserves the benefit of the
doubt in this case though far too many
doubts it's just the writers things this
register can you give me one thing
that's a glaring untruth like is there
one piece that really sort of unknown no
question that no question that certain
people inside the Pakistani intelligence
service the is I knew about Osama bin
Laden's whereabouts absolutely no
evidence in fact plenty of evidence to
the contrary that the two people that he
mentioned the head of the ISI and the
and the chief of general staff of the
army had any any idea same thing with
the the knowledge of the raid beforehand
the US government took extraordinary
measures and and they actually performed
a lot of very sort of spooky voodoo
electronic warfare to make sure that
Pakistan did not see the u.s.
helicopters crossing the border so her
says that that was all gimmick and
planned but it wasn't right so I'm
fascinated by you know sources and
anonymous sources and how you guys
actually get access to this stuff so
when you wrote your piece The Seeker
raid that killed bin Laden how how do
you know who to trust you don't is the
answer every time you use them anonymous
source like that you're putting someone
else's truth out there and essentially
under your name yeah and so both of you
are sort of sharing the risk and you
know the reader has to trust that you
know enough and have evaluated the
source enough to know yeah i think in
recent years people have grown a lot
more mistrustful of anonymous sources
yeah and frankly anonymous sources
themselves have the real anonymous
source as the ones who are legitimate
and the ones who have good reason to
talk to journalists have become a lot
less likely to do so a lot more
reluctant to do so because the
is cracked down on it yeah um and
because there's just so much out there
it's like Gresham's law for journalism
you know the the bad sourcing drives out
the good sourcing so then what's the
reporters responsibility when dealing
with anonymous sources because I get it
especially in overseas situations when
their security issues and things like
that that that's one thing but I think
we see this all the time especially on
cable news now anonymous reporter on
Capitol Hill a Washington source of
administration official like there's
really no level of checking in to me
this list allows reporters and the
administration to just build stories as
they wish I think I think there are two
things that journalists can do and
should do one is they have to explain
precisely why the source had to be
anonymous whether it's the source had to
be anonymous because he was speaking
against the wishes of his boss yeah the
source insisted on anonymity because the
source has an agenda to pursue but the
source is generally reliable in the past
yeah you need to be able to say things
like that right but they ever give us
that kind things very rarely give us
that context the other thing I would do
is you don't need to mention the fact
that you have sort by the way when
journalists say sources told me it's a
it's very curious use of the plural yeah
because most times sources refer to a
source um gotta be I was always and I
there are times when I've you look at
past TV appearance and I said sources I
meant a source I didn't do it
deliberately but it's become such yeah
such a part of the lexicon and I think
it's I think it's that in and of itself
phrase the trust but the other thing is
if you're reporting something
authoritative Lee report it talks say it
use it your own voice and say you know
this is what the White House is doing
don't say administration officials tell
me what the White House is doing say you
know this is what I think the White
House is doing you talk to people they
had given you information really is that
the irony of this that we have so much
personality driven media yeah and yet
reporters wanted we're still they want
to seem like they're they want to see
Usher about our show but they want you
did not that it's just a i think frankly
there is something sexy about saying a
source close to the administration yeah
um you don't need to do that i don't and
i really don't think that the audience
expects that anymore i don't think that
i think people were very skeptical media
consumers in some ways perhaps too
skeptical that's a whole other
discussion but we don't need to hear
someone citing anonymous or
what we need what we want from people is
some sense of authenticity and authority
but in their own voice that's how you do
it yeah so then my last question that I
think ties all this together between the
media and bin Laden everything else is
that now these pictures and yeah other
bits of the story or leaking out from
our government how do you as a reporter
decide what to trust when the
government's down well in this case the
government for a long time has been
looking through what they call the
pocket litter that they found when the
Navy SEALs you know if you remember the
zero dark thirty movie actually
portrayed this part pretty accurately
trash bags full of full of documents and
computer disks the government actually
is planned to relieve actually in in
tranches before have released for
example documents that that he had on
his possession that were already
published by the US government today's
release and I just looked at it before I
came here was a a series of letters that
he wrote to al Qaeda lieutenants you
know throughout you know the several
years he was in about about the timing
of the release is just chords down it's
always hard to believe that but it's you
know it's quince dental I think I think
the Obama administration for reasons
noble they want to contribute to history
and this is an extremely important
person history and his writings
extremely extremely important as were
Hitler's I mean this is essentially the
internal this is the diary of Osama bin
Laden at least but at the same time it
does remind people that this was an
Obama administration operation and Obama
deserves the credit for that so right so
you really think it's a coincidence that
I her story comes out and then just yeah
chicly to we it's not magically because
it takes a month takes months to do this
so there's no there's no way that the
bureaucracy could function in such a way
that they could magically release the
documents that they've released there so
so now III know it's not uh I know it is
a coincidence uh you know and and but
but I also know that that it is no
coincidence that these documents are
presented in a way that sort of puts the
capture of Osama bin Laden and a light
that says well core al Qaeda is defeated
but of course we have lots of other
problems now yeah that's a whole other
but I guess the main thing is that the
bureaucracy is pretty broken huh
conspiracies takes a long time for the
bureaucracy to even figure out how to
vet consensus can you imagine there you
go all right well I'm really curious
what you guys think about the original
bin Laden story this new Seymour Hersh
article reporters anonymous stuff we
talked about this all the time has the
NSA changed your feelings on how the
government reacts to you and your
privacy let us know in the comments
right now